hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be showing from this year's
Norway chess it is not the classical
section just yet before the classical
section we have one full day of Blitz
Games and this is a very special game
from round two and it's a very special
game because Magnus Carlsen is facing
lucash the youngest player ever to have
a defeated Magnus Carlsen uh and today
is his 17th birthday so uh it's always
uh you know weird when you play someone
again on your birthday you know you
either have a great birthday or you you
have a terrible one and uh well even
World Chess championships have been
played on uh certain players birthdays
and they have lost to those games so
it's a crazy game it's a crazy opening
let's check out what happened and uh
well will English have a a happy
birthday or not so Magnus has the white
pieces and he opens with Pawn to B3 he
goes for the ninja Larson attack we have
Pawn to E5 Bishop to beat unites the C6
and now the immediate Pawn to C4 we have
Pawn to D5 cap actress captures and now
a knight to C3 just attacking the queen
all very standard stuff with Queen to E6
and now Knight to F3 with Bishop to D7
and already we move into new territory
there is a game where Ponte E4 was
played but here Magnus plays Pawn to E3
and it is now already as of move 7 that
we have a completely new game so here we
have Castles by Gucci for a queen side
castles and Magnus prepares kingside
castles he plays Bishop to E2 Pawn to F5
and now castles King side and now of
course you know what's coming at Magnus
will be attacking on the queen side and
gookish will be attacking on the king's
side so Pawn to E4 chasing away the
Knight Knight the G5 attacking the queen
and now Queen back to E8 uh we have
pawned the F4 by Magnus now uh cementing
that Knight on G5 but of course he's
just baiting Pawn to H6 so Pawn to H6
Knight to H3 and now Knight to F6 we
have rooked to C1 now nicely aligning
The Rook with the King and C8 so of
course a nice prophylactic King to B8 by
Gucci preparing Pawn to B4 and now
Bishop to E6 putting pressure on the B3
Pawn uh Pawn to B4 by Magnus and now
Queen to D7 putting pressure on that D2
Pawn but Magnus just defensive with
knights the B1 so if you look at
magnus's Knights it seems like he's just
you know horsing around not really doing
good work uh but it's uh he actually
does have a plan the Knight here is very
nicely defending the D2 Pawn there's no
way to do anything in the center uh
Magnus just wants to push on the queen
side and this Knight
uh well later on it can even go for
example to F2 to H1 to G3 and then to
put pressure on the F5 Pawn so here
Knights the E7 at we have Knight the
bishop to E5 by Magnus already
threatening the C7 pawn and Knight F to
D5 by gokash with Bishop to C form and
now King to AAA sidestepping this
diagonal uh Queen to B3 and now uh B5
here is actually a beautiful move uh it
looks like something you don't want to
play because it opens up your king but
it's it's a great it just completely
stops White's attack and not a move you
spot in blitz so instead we have
knighted the C6 here uh putting pressure
on the bishop and Bishop back to B2 by
Magnus we have Rook to Jade now
preparing to push on the king Side Pawn
to G5 is coming and Knight the C3 we
have Pawn to G5 and the bishop captures
on D5 we have Bishop captures Queen
capture Sun D5 and the Magnus trades of
everything as he needs to stop that King
side attack so captures captures and
just Rook the C2 he has to defend the D2
on Pawn to G4 Knights the F2 and pawn to
A5 now sorry Pawn to A5 by glucose
putting pressure on that B4 Pawn uh B
captures an A5 and The Rook captures on
A5 and now just to Rook to A1 as you
need to defend that A3 Pawn with Bishop
to G7 offering a trade of Bishops and
the Magnus uh obliges Bishop captures
Rook captures and now Knights the H1 and
now uh what we've discussed the Magnus
wasn't just horsing around he actually
does have a plan for this Knight the F
the f51
is the back of the pawn chain is going
to be a weak pawn and the magnets will
put a knight on G3 to attack it so Rook
to D7 and now Knights to G3 with uh King
to be bringing the king into the game uh
Rook 8 to A2 doubling up on the second
rank to add more uh the defense to that
D2 Pawn Knights the d8 and now King to
F2 Magnus brings the king into the game
with knights the E6 and now King to E2
uh Pawn to C6 and now Pawn to A4 we have
King to C7 and now Rook 8 to B2 uh Rook
D to D5 uh doubling up on the fifth Rank
and now Rook the B4 uh we have Knights
the C5 now uh putting pressure on the A4
pawn and Rook C to B2 uh by Magnus now
he says all right if you want you can
capture on A4 uh but Lucas does not
capture right away it's perfectly fine
to capture there's no reason not to do
and do it it's just that it's Blitz he
probably trusted Magnus uh Rook to A2
adding the fender to the pawn and now
Knights the D3 now this is a beautiful
night and it's one of those nights that
you do not want to have next to your
king Rook back to B1 and now Pawn to B5
by Magnus by googash and Magnus now has
to advance his Pawn otherwise he would
lose the Rook on A2 so Pawn to A5 but
now Lucas will just win it pawn to B4
the Knight nicely defends it and now the
pawn is attacked twice Pawn to A6 and
now King to B6 Lucas will now be winning
that past a pawn Rook beat the A1
uh Magnus defense but the problem is
Rook to B5 uh we have King to D1 but now
just Pawn to B3 Rook the A3 and pawn to
B2 and now Magnus has to abandoned the a
file with his Rook Rook to B1 and now
bookish just wins upon Rook captures an
A6 Rook captures with check King
captures and now Knight to E2 uh King to
A5 can guish now grab the full point
here Knights the D4 attacks the rook and
the pawn and now Rook the B6 here gukesh
again trusts Magnus King to A4 and it's
game over uh Magnus can just resign here
if you capture the pawn uh there's no
defense against Rook C5 attacks the
Knight and threatens Rook to C1 so I
will be completely winning however Rook
the B6 was played and not Magnus gets
his King closer into the action King to
C2 now King A4 again very strong Lucas
starts advancing the C pawns upon the C5
Knight captures on F5 and now Rook the
B4 we have Knights the D6 uh and King to
B6 um preparing to kick away the Knight
here Knight captures an E4 and now Pawn
to C4 so all of a sudden it is Magnus
who is up upon even though Google
beautifully won that uh passed a pawn
Knight the C3
uh uh uh of course or uh getting that to
a beautiful Square here uh now you might
even put the knights the D1 uh to go
after the pawn or Knight the D5 check
will will be very nice so King to C5
stopping that and now Pawn to F5 Magnus
starts advancing his past F Pawn King to
D6 with Pawn to F6 King to E6 and now
just Rook to F1 putting the Rook behind
the pass Pawn uh Rook the B7 uh guarding
the F7 Square so you can just Advance it
and now Knight the E4 now again
threatening nice the C5 check if the
knight from uh D3 ever moves uh so Rook
the A7 are getting rid of those ideas
and preparing Rook to A1 uh Pawn to F7
Magnus just trades everything off Rook
captures an F7 Rook captures with King
captures and knights the D6 check he
will win the C4 Pawn so King the E6
Knight captures in C4 removes the
defender of the Knight on D3 and now you
have to move it and lose the beat you
Pawn but luckily Lucas has knighted the
E1 check and kill also wins the G2 Pawn
so King captures on B2 we have Knight
captures and G2 and now King to C3 so
Magnus is up upon he's gonna start
pushing his Central pawns and Lucas will
win the H2 pawn and start advancing his
King side pawns but still for the moment
he's down upon Knight to E1 Pawn to D4
sorry Pawn to D4 Magnus starts advancing
Knight to F3 and now Pawn turn
uh E4 with uh H5 we have pointer D5 with
check King the E7 and now King the D3 we
have Pawn to H4 King to E3 and now
Knight captures and H2 and it's equal
material Magnus has the two Central
pawns uh and Gucci has the two outside
pass pawns so Ponte E5 uh G3 and now
Knight to D2 here D6 check is the way to
go Magnus played Knight to the D2 and
now bookish uh can win the game actually
Ponte H3 was played with Knight to F3
and now Knight the G4 check this is
winning for gukash but uh it takes a lot
to win the uh the other check Knight to
F1 check is winning on the spot because
after King to E2 there's no defense H2
and you can't stop H1 uh even if you
capture let's say you capture here uh H1
queen king day two you even Queen the
other Pawn so there's really nothing to
discuss here however it's Blitz uh they
were both like on five seconds on the
clock with increment Knight to G4 check
was played King F4 and now upon the H2
not Magnus played King captures on G4 on
G3 H1 Queen lucash promotes his Pawn to
a queen and now King actually King
captures and G4 was played but the PGN
was broken at the time I uh uh used it
for my interface so a couple of weird
moves will be played now Queen F1 King
characters on G4 but the position that
arises will be the same after a D6 check
King D7 Knights the G5 Queen H2 check
King F5 and now Queen to H5 so here we
continue King to F4 Magnuson pin so now
uh of course gookish has to be careful
Queen to G6 Knight to F3 and now Queen
to F7 with check King the E4 Queen to H7
with check King to F4 we have Queen to
F7 with check and King to E4 now this is
objectively winning for lukash but he's
down to some five seconds on the clock
constantly and Magnus is Shifting
between 10 seconds on the clock and 15
seconds on the clock so uh I mean you
have to be very careful it's very easy
to run into a fork here so Queen to C4
with check Knights the D4 blocking this
and now Queen to B4 we have King to D5
Queen to B7 with check King to C5 and
now Queen to E4 and here finally Magnus
advances the Ponte E6 as the Knight
nicely defends it uh King to C8 here
again Magnuson 15 seconds on the plug
bookish five seconds and a king to see
it is the correct move King if you go to
d8 it's a draw if you go to E8 you have
to fight for a draw but see it still
winning for good cash quantity D7 with
check King to C7 and not Knight to be E5
check again you have to go to d8 you
have to stop the pawn from advancing to
E7 at all cost and now Knight back to D4
Magnus just defends everything and he
says all right you either lose some time
or you you know find a way to win this
however Queen to E5 check was played
King to C4 and now Queen to D6 and here
Magnus couldn't uh find the move he
played onto A7 with check and he played
it fairly quickly uh it just wasn't
enough the problem is uh okay if you
capture with uh the queen on E7 then
Knight the C6 check wins the queen if
you capture on this uh sorry on E7 with
the King then Knights the F5 check wins
the queen however uh has just
played King captures on D7 and here
Magnus just had a good laugh he uh you
know showed Booker's hand and he
congratulated him on this wonderful
victory that took only 94 moves so
that's uh that's a ruling game for Blitz
especially since bookish played like 40
of his last moves with five seconds on
the clock uh that is absolutely
incredible so I even have a
photo of it of of the moment let me just
check real quickly I might have it uh
you know there's a chance I have it uh
so let me just quickly check
yeah there you go
I was it was a fine moment there to have
it Magnus very very very happy uh and uh
also happy that he won but Magnus is
very happy that he uh you know
experienced this game so it's not like
you know I lost I'm super sad you know
he he was he was totally okay with it uh
but yeah very nicely done uh wins a game
against Magnus Carlsen on his uh 17th
birthday so I mean what more could you
ask for I'm very happy for him and I
hope he does well in the rest of the
tournament uh so yeah that's the game I
hope you guys enjoyed it it was a really
wild one and we're gonna cover uh cover
some more if you have any suggestions
always use hashtag suggestion that way
it's much easier for me to check out uh
what's been going on and then of course
we are proceeding into the classical uh
segment of the Norway chess 2023. uh so
yeah once again really hope you enjoyed
it very nicely done by gookish it was a
really wild game I would like to think
golfsoftware.com uh Marcus grebel an
anonymous person MK1 and Boondock Punk
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot to really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon uh continuing the
coverage of this wonderful event until
it finishes so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day